oh happy zero need a really die have you
ever had such a healing tradition as
they're so healthy and so smart you go
first baby okay here we go
massaged kale we got some boobs
otherwise known as blueberry Luke's like
blue boobs like getting blue boobed
banana sweet low-fat yogurt ice and I'm
going to tell you my time matters I
shadow is very heavy not doing it in
front of the mirror hey it looks yummy I
should get started on mine
starting with yams and do some
blackberries that make the smoothie
expensive bee pollen he Polly that I
live forever
where you going the farmers market ended
up with some ice witchy
and coconut water I'm Rihanna bitch Oh
electrolytes the most important thing
maca what's maca turn on the blender Jam
right now
you know looking at mine it looks a
little chunky you know what mine's not
chunky enough I gotta ask that's a my
little bit
you feel comfortable good looks great
drink on my move dear yes we have a
perfect friendship we really do we could
maybe do this twice a year a semi-annual
smoothie day a couple of times maybe
couple times a month